I'm juvenile with regeneration Asia I'm
financed for how we increase access to
education and markets that are merging
and example given as Indonesia there are
many HR it's clearly where education is
a critical growing concern and that is
true frankly Aloha but in these emerging
markets we offer tend to focus on the
children stable in education while those
are very critical in status it's also
important to understand the bears an
emerging economy and an entire group of
young adults that are raising those job
but also have literacy most financial
literacy and others that they must
master it were to be able to effectively
manage themselves and their families the
short answer to the question is that
it's a journey not a destination but it
will require partnerships collaborations
between private public and government
entities to be sure and we need to
celebrate the access to education and
that we mobilize many resources and
leverage technology and other creates so
much Chancellor that only that kind of
collaboration of both circus will enable
us to facilitate it's not any one
person's responsibility it's how our
responsibility